Thank you so much.
Yeah.
A lot of people say,
Jack,
your time is so precious and that,
no,
not necessarily.
Really.
Um,
if your time do not have spend on the
things that you feel important or same
thing that you are extremely love to do
it.
Oh,
you're not spending time for the future,
that time.
Normally no use.
So be spending time with the students,
with the schoolmates and discussing
young people.
Cause when I look at the young people,
your eyes,
he reminds me my,
my past.
So I think spending time with the,
it's my honor.
This is the time,
the most
validate,
discuss,
discuss about the dreams.
I think like any kids,
I had a lot of dreams when I young and
most of the dreams never came true.
Now I've been trying to,
I tried the vape now when I'm 53 years
old,
I uh,
I've been working very,
very,
extremely hard in the pastor 30 years,
35 years now.
I think it's time to think about my
young childhood dreams,
to sing songs and being an actor and
painting everything.
I want to try everything that I go.
So you have to work hard.
They can realize a lot of dreams.
That sounded stupid.
Crazy when you were young.
MMM.
Let me say this.
When I started out,
well,
by the way,
I said I worked very hard when I was a
student at university in the university
event.
I was the chairman of the student's
Union of my university and a for my
city,
I spent,
I would say 70% of my time serving in
the student's unit,
supporting young people.
That gives me a lot of lot of experience
that working with the people,
the people relationship,
helping people by helping people,
I can a lot of fun and get out.
When I get them all fun,
I help you more people.
So this is why when I never got an even
one day of training to do business,
when I stepped my,
my company,
I know how to do with the other people.
So it's not only knowledge that as a
student they should alert,
you should learn how to serve people,
how to work with people,
how to team up with the people.
So in the future,
remember one thing that we know Iq,
he,
if you want to be successful to have
great q,
because econ knows how to work with
people.
If you,
no matter how smart you are,
but you never know how to,
how to work with people,
you will never succeed your dream.
We never can.
It's just the old dream.
And then I cue is a make you not make
stupid mistakes.
You wouldn't make you live longer.
And the other thing in the future,
if you want to be respected,
you should have l.
Q.
The Q of Love is also very important.
So these are the things when you have
these skills,
he eeq Iq and El Que,
most of the students pay streamline
attention to the ICU,
but they don't pay attention to the
queue.
If you don't have the El Que,
you'll go nowhere.
So all the dreams you have the based on
these things.
And I never know that I was a,
I will,
I will be jumping to the internet time.
And when I jumped in the Internet time
when I started my career are the 1995 I
started Internet China and terrible
years for four years,
made a lot of mistakes and you know,
stupid mistakes and partner and all in
a,
in a,
in a railway.
1999 was when I started Alibaba.
I told my team that we may not succeed,
but somebody will.
And I never know and we never realized
after 18 years we can achieve them much.
So if it is your,
your dream,
you can never go for,
if it is a group stream can go further.
So I make our Alibaba dream,
not my dream is a dream of 18 founders.
Later it become a dream today become a
dream of 60,000 people.
And we make the dream tribe and making
sure that everybody we will try.
Our dream is to enable,
everybody can realize the intrepreneur
dreams through the Internet.
So young people remember,
don't worry about it,
you know,
is that a silly dream?
Now if you really believe it's a,
it's a great dream.
So believe something that you're really
passionate about.
Don't believe it because the other
people think it is important.
I never think when most people like it,
I don't like it when most people don't
like it.
I will think about it.
This is that you'll make yourself
unique.
You are you and doing business is about
do anything is that we,
because you are so unique,
there are about 7 billion people in the
world,
but there's only one you.
That's what we see.
So doctor Ma,
a lot of young people and a lot of
students have a harder time sort of
sticking to their dreams.
So after one field glass or one field
acting audition,
they immediately get discouraged.
So what advice can you give the young
people so that they can continue
sticking towards their dream even in
spite of all the obstacles?
Yeah.
One thing,
why have a dream?
You have the same one in the treme is
great.
The thing behind the dream is tough,
right?
So when you want to dreams that you have
to ask yourself,
what do you want to sacrifice?
Not Say I want to do anything to get my
train,
but you know what?
What are the things you want really want
to do?
You have a failure.
You are mistakes people don't like you.
People don't team with you and all this
stuffs.
When you have a dream,
you have to think the backside of the
trim very clearly.
So everybody,
ask yourself,
what do you have
right?
And what do you want?
A very important,
what will you give up?
If you don't think about what we give
up,
you will not have what you have.
So
when I start my business,
I know Internet,
(990) 590-9999 nineties nobody believed
Internet in China will happen.
So I want to sell my products.
I know today as a salesman,
I go out,
can people,
if I talk to 10 businesspeople,
10 business people always say no.
Why?
People want to help you.
People say,
nobody helping me.
Why?
People should help you.
People will help you.
That is extremely,
you're lucky people don't help you.
That's very common.
So when you go out,
nobody,
nobody would have a deal with you.
You say,
yeah,
I'm right.
Nobody do with it.
If you've got one deal,
you should be honored,
extremely happy because you are extra
ordinary.
So don't be discouraged when people
don't help for you.
Why people should help you.
You should have earned the right to be
helped,
right?
So this is so when you have a dream,
you have asked what are the things you
going to pay for the trees?
So that's a very interesting
perspective,
a doctor really understanding what
you're willing to give up.
Now we want to talk about this role
model that you've always often talked
them rather often talked about in a lot
of your interviews,
forest gump.
Um,
often times you cite this coat from
that,
from that movie,
life is a box of chocolates.
Um,
but with that we wanted to know more
about how you stumbled upon forrest gump
and what kind of,
what kind of different perspective in
the world,
uh,
has watching that movie,
given to you?
Yeah,
that's a very interesting question.
The day I watched the forrest gump was
in a friend's home in Seattle and that
week was my most frustrated,
just made period.
I was so upset.
I was cheated by my friends and I failed
like five projects all film.
So I almost to say,
well,
you know this,
the,
the people I work with,
they're very smart
and um,
we know that Internet was not easy.
90 95,
90,
96,
907.
But when we,
we did not realize it's so tough.
Then I was happy to be in Seattle,
in my friend's home and he had a video,
the forrest gump of watch that,
that evening and I,
I watched the movie.
I think we have to stay foolish.
We saw a dream.
Don't think we are smart.
We have to stay foolish with their
dreams.
And we have to continue be simple.
Like forrest gump is a very simple,
he's not smart guy.
He continued to do running round money.
He thinks that the sub,
he said nobody,
you know,
he will only want to make business.
Bennett from the catcher shrinks.
A lot of people want to make business
and make money by catch wills,
shocks,
you know,
you've got to do business who was a big
companies.
So I thought that time,
yes,
he's right.
We should serve normal people.
We should catch shrimps.
We should have supporting small
business.
So be simple,
stay foolish,
and no matter what,
you know,
just the continuum and do not complain.
Others only complete yourself.
Checking what's the problem was me,
did I change myself late?
I fall.
A lot of people feel because when they
feel they always complain about the
others.
Ah,
that's his fault.
That's that problem,
that,
that problem.
And only those people always check their
own problems.
These people survive.
These people succeed.
Four years for Pi,
the age,
18 years.
I don't think Ali Baba me complaint a
lot.
If you complain,
you have to have a solution.
If there's no solution for complain,
don't complain.
That's it.
So in the movie forrest Gump,
you talked about the shrimp,
right?
There were basically days before they
finally got that big hall of shrimp.
So forrest had to go through a lot of
failure before he got success.
With that,
you've already said the young people
that they should be able to learn more
from their failures rather than their
successes.
What do you think the types of failures
young people make that they should learn
the most from?
Oh yeah.
Let me tell you that one day I was a
reading.
Yeah.
Reading a biography of general in the
set up the Second World War
and I feel impressed not
is how much victories successful,
better that he achieved.
I think,
wow.
You know,
if I were better,
if I were John Young man at that time I
could do better.
But I was impressed by how many suffers,
that terrible experience that he
survived.
That's surprised me.
The grant,
the grand grandfather always tell us,
you know,
Jack,
I've been doing that much.
I made a lot of mistakes.
I still surviving as a wall that if he
say,
you know,
I been achieved that much and say,
hey,
you know,
if I were your age though,
at that time I could do better.
So people were few proud when the day
when you tell your grandson about how
much tough days you have gone through.
I think one day I share with my kids,
my grandchildren,
how much Ali Baba have gone through the
tough days.
The mistakes doing business.
It's just like a go to the battlefield,
the survivor wings.
No matter how brief you are,
your dad,
people forget or you within three days.
Yeah,
but if you survive,
you always have chance and go to battle.
Feud is that I experienced the soldier
know that are held to hit a himself and
then fight young soldiers just to go out
to fight.
There are a gift from the reasons for
success.
There are various reasons too,
for one person to be successful,
but there are almost the same reasons
for people who feel greedy,
right?
Round team round too fast with too much
money.
By the way,
you will never make big mistakes where
you don't have money,
but people say,
if I have the money,
I'm going to do a big business.
No,
no,
no.
Remember that.
All the mistakes the other people made
you will make it
so you have to learn.
If you want to be successful,
learn the mistakes the other people
learn.
Learn from the mistake the other people
may not because you will avoid these
mistakes because you know how to face
these mistakes and troubles when these
things come
right.
When you serve a lot of our mistakes,
we see,
wow,
these guys coming,
these mystic come how the Jack Ma did a
how bill gates did it or how a Bama did
it.
You know,
when the tough day comes is it's not
because you can't avoid it because when
the problem comes,
how your face,
it was great attitude,
then you succeed.
Yeah,
I'm doctor are there than that.
Uh,
I think one time you also mentioned that
giving
up is possibly one of the biggest
failures that the other person can do.
But I think when it comes to the young
people,
oftentimes you have our crazy dreams and
we tried to seek advice from older
people or more experienced people who
sometimes tell us that's not going to
work or this is how you make it work.
How do we make it happen such that we
still continue our dreams,
but at the same time we take criticism.
Um,
but we don't give up because more often
than not,
that's what happened.
If you have a crazy dreams,
don't talk to her grandfather.
Um,
if you have a crazy dream,
very important is that you have to find
the people around you.
When,
when we invest a company,
I want not all looking at the founder,
I want to see the people who work with
the founder of whether did you believe
him.
If he is the only person that believe in
the dream,
that's very dangerous.
He's not a crazy dream is a crazy
person.
But you have to find a group of people
who are all believed.
They all crazy.
Something interesting,
right?
Cause it's easier to make a work person
crazy.
But if you make it the whole team crazy,
something interesting.
This is what I did.
Early days of Alibaba,
I made a speech in America talk about
the value,
mission and management way of running an
internet company.
That was very early 2001,
two.
There is a guy in American guys sitting
there and say,
hey,
this is a crazy guy,
internet at the survivors to make profit
or revenue for Gabba,
Carnival Valley imaging and team
working.
You know this is old.
This is old liars.
He said,
you're crazy.
I say,
sir,
welcome to Ali Baba someday.
So he came to Ali Baba,
spend a few days.
The day when he left,
he said,
Jack,
I thought you are crazy.
Now I found a 100 crazy guys and your
company
because we believe what we are doing.
Yeah,
it's easiest to make you believe,
but if you can make a group of team
belief and continued to do it dancing.
So I think
there are,
if it's crazy or not,
the only testing is the idea.
If you want to make a company is sounds
crazy.
You're customer love it.
If the custom like it,
your team like it,
you know it's not crazy.
If the customer does not like it,
do not like it.
Your team don't like it,
forget about it.
You have to change yourself,
dude.
Even if you have a crease,
ideas don't believe you're always right.
You have to learn all the by.
By the past 18 years we have changed at
least the 18 big major changes.
We are not the Ali Baba last a year.
Every week,
every year we have different company.
Yeah.
Right.
So this is,
you have to change all the time to be
sure that we don't care about how the
other people say you're crazy.
We care about is this something really
different?
Really make the,
make the difference.
That's what we care about.
So a lot of the students here are young
entrepreneurs themselves and they have a
lot of crazy ideas and they wanted to
make those ideas happen.
Since you're the UNC,
that special advisor for young
entrepreneurship and small businesses,
what do you think the role of young
entrepreneurs and small businesses are
in the country and had making the
country grow?
True?
Good way of,
I do want to do it.
The first thing I advise give is think
about what will you give up,
right?
And next thing I want to give advisors
how many years you want to reach for
that goal.
A lot of people have this idea,
I want to be 16 next month or next year
or next two week.
Forget about,
there's no such opportunity in this
world that you can succeed next week.
There's no better opportunity that can
sit next to year cause young people,
most people like the main,
right.
18 years ago,
we don't have money,
we don't have technology,
we don't have a relationship,
we don't have any powerful person
supporting us.
I started my business,
18 people.
We only get the 50,000 US dollars,
18 people together in my apartment so we
don't have anything.
And when I started Alibaba,
when I started my internet business
year,
1995 I started with 2000 he has
daughters.
All of the money from my relatives and
friends.
I was started.
But I know one thing people like us
don't have money.
Technology,
don't have any relationship or any
things.
We know we wink for the future.
I know if I,
I started doing it 10 years later we'll
win and in the 10 years what I would
give up,
who our partner was,
what the things will be different than
me,
how can I live longer at instead of live
happier.
So the world is very interesting.
If you want to live happier,
you may live very shot.
If we want to live longer,
life is a bit good,
very tough.
You have to exercise every day,
right?
So this is,
this is the live balance.
So young people,
when you have a dream you want to do is
think about how many years you wanted to
make this thing happen.
If you think it's about three years,
I can be successful per pair for 10
years.
If you think I have five years to
succeed for Pepo 15 years
and they,
if you think 10 years was succeed,
Ms Succeed in eight years.
So you should have a long preparation
determination and these all the things
you have to thing about,
there is no great opportunity then make
you succeed next week,
next month,
next the year.
There is a notice this fancy great idea.
That's a really crazy,
yeah.
I think I speak for Mikey and everyone
here,
this might've been 20,
the most insight took minutes of my life
and our lives.
So thank you very much for sharing your
knowledge and experience with us.
Thank you.
Um,
on behalf as,
hello everyone.
Thank you very much.
So we'll remember that through.
Find out what we're willing to give up,
make sure not just Iq but he q and l q
as well.
And lastly,
never ever stopped believing in our
genes.
So thank you very much Mr Ma for your
thymine.
Thank you.
On behalf of the students at Delasalle.
Hello,
Jack.
Dan.
No.
Doctor Jack Reservoir La.
I like to think,
uh,
Doctor Jack for an insightful discussion
earlier.
Uh,
we were talking about a framework that
I've been doing with the government for
the past so many years,
which focuses on money.
I mean,
mentorship,
money and market,
the three most powerful ms in really
helping our micro and small
entrepreneurs.
And uh,
I invited about 50 entrepreneurs here.
Most of them from the brick and mortar
business.
A number of them are in the digital
economy,
three of them are quite successful and
they will share their insights and
questions with you.
And uh,
I think the brick and mortar are here
because they're scared of the changing
landscape,
the structure that is happening in the
way things are happening.
So I wanted to ask you,
uh,
okay.
During the old economy or the brick and
mortar businesses have to fear that
much.
What is their solution to preventing
themselves from disappearing?
Okay.
Yeah.
I think the,
uh,
the old economy should not fear,
but they should have it
change immediately.
The past 20 years,
Internet technology changed the world.
But this,
it will speed up next 30 years and every
three years,
it's just like a 30 years.
So if you do not stop the change,
it's going to be tough.
It's going to be really tough.
I'm not scaring people because I've been
doing that in China for years.
Telling people that the new business
motto.
So how it just like the older days,
if you using horses,
uh,
buffaloes too and the other guy use
electricity,
you don't have channels at all.
If you are doing business,
do you think about idesign and I make an
eye cell called a,
b,
two c,
but the other guys,
because the new technology,
they become consumer to b consumer to
eat becomes CTB.
They become a tailor made.
They use using the logistic.
So there's a social justice to network.
They're reached the market a quicker,
faster than you are not.
Oh they using the Internet to find the
customers abroad.
Cross the board.
They using data technology much cheaper.
You don't have chance to win.
So I think
please change quickly.
It's not a competitor killing you.
It's the future.
Kill you
if you kill yourself and how you can
change,
embrace the change.
Do not be scared about technology.
Technology,
I would assume today is so simple and
easy.
The only thing spent a time on that.
I think because you're an entrepreneur,
you're smart enough.
If you really sit down together for
three hours deep learning,
it would change.
A lot of people just don't like it.
I think.
I know the world is so deep.
This world is so difficult to change a
successful people.
That's what people have a millions of
ways to tell you.
I succeed yesterday.
So you guys again,
so let,
let us love from young people
today.
Technology,
Internet technology as so simple,
so easy.
And most of the Internet companies like
us,
we give them free technology,
free services.
Why not try free young people?
Because we try free to succeed.
So I would say don't be scared.
Don't be feared.
Fear just to go ahead.
If you don't use it,
it's just like last century.
You refuse to use electricity.
It's going to be dangerous.
And by the way,
it only takes about first to three
years.
You are totally different.
We talked about the three M's.
One of the three M's was mentorship.
Lasalle is a great school,
a great one to preschool.
I still have to get my diploma.
I started in Lasalle,
but I still should finish one more
subject.
That's the identity off of things and I
agree with Dr [inaudible] because uh,
you need the cue more than Iq in a
sense.
All my life,
my passion is to help many of our micro
entrepreneurs.
We discussed the Labor of poverty.
Here is the cost for our drug problem
and for us to enable our small
entrepreneurs.
Many of them are survival entrepreneurs
to lift up from poverty,
we have to create the next part of the
PMS,
which is the money side and the
marketplace.
What are you views to enable these
people to cross and be able to access
the money in the market?
Yeah,
I think first small business must,
must have big dreams and big companies
should have small steps.
Big Company always think a big,
you will fall down.
They companies should have small steps
every week,
every day,
every year.
I must have reached this small but small
dreams.
Small companies,
you have big dreams.
I now today serve 20 customers.
How can I serve 200 customers in two
years?
How can a sub 2000 customers,
what are the ways that I can serve 2000
customers?
How can I make this 10 customers who
using my services that'd be happier,
healthier and continued to be,
we tried to make every customer of my
company to be the advertisers or
salespeople for a company because in
this way you have to making sure your,
your product's good,
but
the government should build up the
infrastructure of commerce.
What is the infrastructure of commerce
is at the mentorship?
We should have a lot of,
uh,
business schools,
not necessarily mbs.
I'm not a particular fan of the
traditional Mba.
The Mba,
they make people sometime very stupid
because business is,
you have to be flexible.
You have to change yourself.
To me,
no,
it's not.
It's not.
Everything can be standard,
right?
So
whipped the mentorships and we also have
the money reaching,
market reaching.
And also I think the technology region.
So what we call is that this country,
I cannot see,
I know a lot about the Philippines,
but when I see over 100 million people,
99% of the business of this country as
small,
medium size companies,
we should do it up.
The infrastructure of supporting small
business,
making sure that every small business
are able to reach the money and today
it's impossible to let the big banks to
do it.
We should have used a new technology to
do it,
which I call inclusive financing,
can be down by Internet technology.
Today,
Ali Baba in China,
Ali pay,
we serve more than half billion people,
young people in China using mobile phone
payment.
We don't have so many credit card
system,
crack hard China,
but people say,
Jack,
you know it's impossible.
Do the payment in China in the past 15
years,
people keep on,
criticize us.
Say,
how can you do payment online?
You don't have a check.
You'd have a credit card system.
You'd have a credit system.
You don't have enough banks.
How can you do greg?
Because we don't have the check because
we'd have the credit card system.
We make the most of the vast payment
system in the wall.
So Philip Pink,
I think you have the opportunity to make
the woe,
the best
texting or Fintech in the wall because
you have so many mobile phones.
You have set more than 7,000 islands.
It's possible for banks to have offices
in [inaudible] covering everywhere,
but mobile phone coverage everywhere.
We shouldn't make the pink a cashless
society when you have a cashless
society.
Everybody wished my wig Casio said that.
No,
no corruption and lives easier.
Totally agree.
We have basically two telco guys here
are in a school globe.
Eric Alberto smart and plap blamed them
for the slow Internet.
No.
Honestly,
honestly,
it's unfair to blame anybody.
Let me see this.
Where's the opportunity?
Opportunity exists.
The errors.
Most people complain
if you can solve the complaint,
you have the chance where we started the
Ali Baba,
the speed of Internet in China was
terrible.
Much worse than today's Philippine.
Oh,
much worse
at that time knowing even three g.
But that's not an excuse for mobile
phone companies too.
Hello.
Slow speed has slowed the services
faster.
Speed has fastest speed services,
but it's a great opportunity for,
for the telecommunication companies to
this investment guarantee.
You will get the written back.
They're going into the four g now.
So that's going to speed up the
Internet.
I think it's,
this is,
this is the opportunity for everybody.
If the four g five g's continue to,
it's going to the country.
Good.
Make everybody good.
And finally we'll be good
before we go to the students to ask
questions.
I wanted to just call to a successful
techman years Robbie Antonio.
Uh,
briefly.
Can you ask Jack Time question.
Hello morning.
Mr Ma.
Um,
the smartest people in the world seems
to be very divided in the issue of
blockchain technology.
Uh,
what is your current stance towards
this?
I seem to have research that you're
predisposed toward it.
And how does that conflict with the
overarching goal of China batting at the
exchange and the technology?
Right.
Say that again.
Blockchain,
the blockchain and bitcoins.
Okay.
Bitcoins,
right?
Well I'm,
I'm,
I'm a believe there of the blockchain
technology
and uh,
we have a specific a team in the
company,
Ali and to financing focus on
researching on that because we are
believer of globalization.
We are believer of free trade in the
future.
The global trade,
global business,
globalization,
there are a lot of money transferring
what is the safe straight away,
what is the most efficient away that to
do that.
So we put a lot of efforts on that.
So I wouldn't say,
let me see this about technology and
otherwise
competent like us.
We should not the wing our market by
advertising dollars,
we should win our market by innovation.
Alibaba should not get our profit from
the size of the business.
We should get our profit from the
technology that will be invested in
side.
We invested in heavily nine years ago
studying,
I'll clock computing a big datas now for
financing.
We invested heavily on blockchain but
bit coin of this.
I'm not big fan of that yet.
Let me say this.
Um,
company like us,
I think last century,
if you have a technology,
you want to keep it to yourself
today in 21st century,
if you have a technology,
the only way to make you powerful is
enabled others.
Even in there we are competitors.
So we,
Ali Baba was spent
millions of dollars on technology and
when we spend the money on the
technology will making sure this
technology is inclusive to the others.
So block chain technology is the big
investment that we invest in all that,
but we SSA,
we also would love to partner with
others.
Others.
Got It.
Okay.
Um,
Robbie basically raised the money on his
company called revolution.
He,
this is the first Filipino company who
validated 1 billion US dollar.
So congratulations to this guy.
Thank you.
I have another very successful tech
[inaudible] surpass next.
Can you ask your question quickly?
Hi,
good morning,
Joe.
Morning.
Uh,
my question is around the ead WTP,
a initiative that Alibaba has taken a,
what are the implications of this for
Southeast Asia?
And I guess more importantly,
uh,
for traditional businesses and
retailers,
how should they view the ewt tp knowing
that it can be very disruptive to their
current business models?
Thank you so,
so much for this question,
but you'd governor tpe stands for
electronic world trade platform.
A lot of people don't like
globalization.
I think globalization did a fantastic
job in the past 30 years.
They pump up the global trade,
but it's a growing pain.
It's a stew,
a baby only 30 years old.
The thing,
the problem is that it benefit 20% of
the developer.
The countries,
80% of developing countries don't have
Charles Young people don't have chance.
The globalization,
the of 30 years was control.
The by 60,000 big companies we think
should at least the 16 million or 30
minutes or 60 minutes.
Small Business.
Young people should be able to sell
small business like anybody sitting here
intrepreneurs Philip Pink.
Think about how you can sell your small
business here,
can sell products to China,
to career,
to Europe as well as your service is
good products.
Good.
You should be able to compete with any
big companies.
This is my belief.
So he,
WTP is tried to boot up a platform,
not organization.
I feel sorry for WTO where you put 200
government and ministers in their one
room to agree on something impossible,
right?
But if we put the 2000 business people
in a one room,
we can't agree on something.
The only thing do we want to do
business.
So He WTP,
we work with WTO is this is the two
tarts,
zero version of WTO supporting small
business,
young people that we encouraging every
government to set free trade or zoos or
small business.
There are so many of free trade zones,
any country,
but all of these free traders,
those are designed for big companies or
small business.
If you want to sell things outside the
country,
the government would never give you 24
hours customed to careers.
Big Company can,
you cannot.
So we want the beauty of a process,
a platform,
our way of doing business.
Then every small business you can global
sell,
global buy,
global pay,
global delivery and global travel.
And you can have a marketplaces online
and this is what we believe.
I,
we come here,
Ali Baba,
come here to,
to Philippine.
Last night I arrived like at 10 o'clock
we had a meeting then us,
we had the meter until later.
12 or two hours discussing how we can
build up the infrastructure of doing
business in Philippine,
the payment system,
the marketplace system,
the logistic system.
When we build up that,
the purpose is to making sure these
small business can sell their things to
China to do the other part,
to do militia.
Now the ewt be the first project we
launched is in Malaysia and we hope that
every country in South East Asia can
join the EDA blue tp.
Every country have a free trader Zos for
small business entrepreneurs,
they're a marketplace rich.
There are money reached logistic rich
mentorship training rich and Iq rich so
they can do business.
This is what I want anywhere in the
world.
Any young people in any country,
open a mobile phone.
You can order products from everywhere
in the wall and then get a product
within 72 hours.
And this is the goal that we want rich
in 20 years.
And ewg for today.
The first the sample we're testing a
militia.
Very good.
So far so very good.
So when we have that model where we're
bringing to Asia,
any countries,
if we are interested in
thank you.
And the last us should from a Mr
Lavista,
uh,
the youngest entrepreneur we have here.
Uh,
he uh,
he dreamed up putting in solar panels in
everybody's rooftop.
And how old are you?
2024,
24,
just 24 years old.
And he's a finish my university of 24.
Go ahead.
It's like your mission serta use
technology to uplift developing
countries is so inspiring.
And apart from the slowest Internet,
the Philippines also has the most
expensive electricity,
the worst traffic and many other worsts.
So I'd like to ask,
what are your other ideas apart from
ecommerce and Fintech,
the solve developing world problems in
energy
infrastructure and agriculture to end
poverty in the developing world.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Well that is this say this.
People consider Ali Baba is that you
commerce company first.
We're not economists company.
We are ecommerce enabler.
We do not a buy and a sell ourself.
This is the first well different from
Amazon.
Amazon,
they buy their self,
their ecommerce.
We make,
we help other company to be ecommerce.
Second,
ecommerce is less than 20% of our
business,
so I'll leave up a listing listed in New
York state stocks.
That's the only 20% of our business.
We ask ourselves one thing
18 years ago in my apartment.
Our dream is to survive.
Our dream is to making sure Alibaba will
survive and be us the business.
And today we have six close to 60,000
employees.
We have so much cash.
We have the greatest technology of the
Internet,
ecommerce,
we have all the results that we have,
what we want our,
we want to make more money.
We think we should have be the aging of
innovation of the world of this century.
We should be a company of the century,
not company of China,
of company of hung tool,
which are using all the resources,
Datas,
people.
We have to enable the,
if you want to be sent company of the
century,
you have to make different.
So we think we want to built up using
this resources.
We have to build up the infrastructure
that every young people,
every small business,
every woman can leverage this
technology,
this technology infrastructure to do
business to culture.
So this is our dream and this is our few
more excited about our revenue,
income or profit income.
Although we have revenue growth,
profit,
we love the things we care about.
The job creations were care about the
efficiency of people doing we care
about.
Young people have opportunities.
We care about women leaderships.
These things would care about.
But if you really ask us what we would
do for sustainable growth,
growth,
what's the meaning of life is happy and
healthy.
We think after Internet we should make
them people that be happy,
be healthy,
so happy and healthy industries.
Uh,
something that we want to do.
If you want to be healthier,
healthy food,
healthy environment,
healthy water,
healthy air.
If you want to be happier,
you should have the belief you have the
valley,
you have the dreams.
I don't want to make this our company
become a company,
a machine of making money
and this is how we do it and I to
sustainable growth is that where you are
healthy and happier you can be,
you can be sustainable and if you want
to be healthy,
environment,
water,
food and psychological,
you'll be how it should have a belief.
Religion,
culture and education.
These are the things that using
technology,
if we can empower these things,
we are the company that are few proud
for working day and night that it worth
it.
Otherwise it does not make any sense or
making more money.
Why can't I spend a lot of money?
This is a tie up I've given by,
you know,
I don't,
I don't dress like a,
I don't wear watches.
No rings,
no.
That place,
I think you know how much money can
speak and only asleep.
One bad.
You can only eat a suite dinners.
It's so that's the meaning of life.
And this is what we want to do.
We have a couple of questions from
students.
Are you ready?
Where are you guys?
Uh,
ladies and gentlemen.
Yeah.
So our esteemed guests,
doctor,
mine has been most kinds.
We agreed to answer some questions for
students so far.
The students,
please introduce yourself and tell us
your year and major are before you ask
your questions.
Okay,
next students.
Hi
Jack Ma.
Um,
I'm a third year industrial engineering
student.
Oh,
my question is,
what would you consider to be your
biggest failure in life and what did you
learn from this experience that you can
share to us students?
Thank you.
Ah,
the,
my biggest mistake that I don't want to
make is the date when I retired,
the company collapse,
right?
This is what I don't want to see.
Because everybody was sick.
Everybody would get out.
Everybody would die.
We'd been working hard for 18 years at
this company while the loss a hundred,
two years.
So we will never see Ali.
Ali Baba is successful because we only
15,
18 years there,
84 years to go.
In the last,
next 80 84 years,
we may have a hundred times or maybe one
minute chaz would disappear.
So my job as his fantasy you,
how can I keep this company growing when
I retire,
when I leave this company is to continue
to grow.
This is why I don't want,
when I'm 80 years old,
70 years old,
I'm sitting still the company I bought,
I should die on the beaches in the
Philip Ping or mopping,
not in the my office cause you don't
want to see an older guy said to 18
years so stupid.
The chairman,
that one work.
So every day I'm thinking about is what
if I leave the company,
the company can continue to grow and if
I cannot make that thing happen,
this is the miss [inaudible] mistake
that I would make.
And there are a lot of mistakes I do is
that I can share a lot of ideas the day
when I retire.
If I,
if I'm a good at the writing,
I would write a Alibaba 1000 where
mistakes,
any mistakes or for example,
when you have a,
when you raise money,
a lot of people when the risk man,
the first thing they will,
they will looking for a fancy office
building
and decorate and wonderful and stat high
greet people,
especially high people from
multinationals.
That's a big mistake I've made when I,
when I have the first of five minute
Usda our foundation,
I started to hire people who used to
work in the vice president of big
companies,
but when they came the destroyed us
because when you are attracted,
you Bolo a Boeing seven four seven
engine putting side,
they're going to destroy your tractor.
You should not find the best of people.
You should find right people and working
them,
develop them,
make your team the best of people.
There's no best people in the market.
The best people is always your own
company.
That's the mystique alert and I want to
share with you.
Thank you.
Okay.
Hello.
Good morning.
My name is [inaudible].
I'm a third year entrepreneurship
student.
Firstly,
welcome to our university and thank you
for visiting us.
My question is,
based on your experiences,
what are the friendships that enjoyed
time and the ups and downs in life?
My question,
my question is based on your
experiences,
what are the friendships that enjoy time
and the ups and downs in life?
Friendships,
the friendships,
right?
Well,
um,
I think the thing that would make me
goals for all the top days,
other friendships.
MMM.
The,
let me say it this way.
I don't invite any of my friends joined
my company from the first day.
But when they join my company,
I make friends with them.
This is the advisor give you,
don't invite your best friend to form a
company with you.
Dumb.
Totally done.
I see so many tragedies.
They're up cases and me succeed.
But most possibly you will fail.
It's better to make friends when they
join the company,
treat them.
But when the companies that bid,
you cannot make friends who,
anybody.
We can make colleague friends.
So friends means when I'm in trouble,
I talked about,
I talked to my I,
to my friend,
uh,
by colleagues,
troubles even to today.
Only days,
whatever problems I have the company
have,
I'd tell them,
oh,
frat,
trust them.
Right?
What's the Raul?
We don't,
we are,
we're going to run out of money in two
weeks.
So when you got to do,
don't shock them by problems.
So friendship things based on trust.
My team trusted me and I trust them.
I know my team can do better than I than
I am.
And I know they can survive.
They will when they're in trouble.
I spent time with them when I'm in
trouble,
I found many of my friends came to talk
to me.
They hot help to me.
Yeah.
Friendship.
Well,
the difference between,
let me tell you this,
business is about a friendship of
beauty.
Okay?
Friendship is about trust building.
Well,
you don't have friends.
You don't have the business.
We don't have trust.
You don't have friends.
That's all the thing.
Very simple.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next.
Okay,
so hello doctor Jah.
A good day.
I'm g o n I am a third year psychology
majors through it then.
So,
and here's my question.
So the trend today is that there are
many young people who do things
simultaneously.
So there are,
they have their full time jobs while
doing their studies or doing part time
work.
Well,
there are others who also wanted to
pursue their plants or passion in doing
business and open up their businesses.
So in the perspective of prior
authorization,
what advice can you give to these young
people who wanted to pursue their dream
of doing business while doing these
other tasks?
Okay,
say that again.
Make it simple.
Okay.
So given that the
young people of the day have a lot of
things that they really wanted to do a,
what advice can you give to the young
people of the day?
Uh,
in terms of prioritization,
what advice can you give to them?
All right,
that's good.
Uh,
first let me say a young people have a
lot of things to do.
He wants to do a lot of things,
is better than the young people.
Was that anything he wanted to do?
Lots of things.
You want to do.
At least you have hope.
I like these kinds of people,
but you have to focus on the things and
how to folks.
What's the priority my way if not,
maybe not correct.
You have to pick up the things that you
are really passionate about.
You love to do it where you do business.
You have to do things,
you believe in,
you love to do it.
If you're not like it,
you don't like it.
You cannot sustain.
So you love it or you have a passion
about it.
This is my priority.
Do not pick up the thing that is
important or your father said it's
important.
You don't think so.
They're could go nowhere.
So Pi r e t to me is where you are tiny.
Pick up the things you,
oh you love,
you're good at,
you know that I can last long.
Don't pick up things that is a big,
that will never lost law and the other
people think is big.
So this is something that I,
that that was m and a by the way,
the pirate ret of your choice of doing
whether study or work at the same
learning way you do the business you
learn from the business way is school.
You have to put the all the knowledge
into practice.
I a lot of people wonder Rizza uh,
we'll,
we'll leave the school or was that a
getting a degree and then go to go to do
business,
be an entrepreneur.
They say Bill Gates succeed.
He did not finish a school in Harvard.
There is only one bill gates.
Don't do that right today it's much
easier.
Your school in the daytime,
in the evening,
open a shop online and buy it herself.
That alert is a great experience.
All join the students units support the
people all work in the part on the
weekend supported this entrepreneur
school companies be a uh,
a,
you know,
a person their work in a weekend.
You learn.
So,
sorry,
I speak a lot today cause I don't think
we can speak every year,
but I,
I want us to tell something that is
helpful.
When you are 20 to 30 years old,
please find a good boss.
A good boss is better than a good
company.
A good boss would discipline you,
train you,
develop you where you have 30 to 40
years old,
tried to do something.
If you really want to do something
yourself,
try to do it from 30 to 40 when you're
40 to 50 years old to something you are
good at.
Don't do something you don't know
anything about.
But when you're 50 to 60 years old,
focusing on helping young people are
your six over 60 years old.
Spent time with the grandchildren.
80%,
right?
Not Everybody,
but most people doing that.
Jack,
uh,
there's an intermediary here.
Um,
yeah,
a woman into been near a serial
entrepreneur.
Her name is Molly [inaudible],
my ela.
You had a question for Jack.
Okay.
Is there a mic,
microphone and after this,
so we have two questions left for the
students,
so please prepare.
I'm good.
Good morning,
doctor.
Mark.
Um,
your friend,
Masa,
son,
um,
histories.
Then hand is deploying $100 billion
vision fund around companies.
Uh,
uh,
deploying the power of ai and the
Internet of things and talks about
singularity.
I wanted to know whether you agree with
them,
you talk about it and what are your
thoughts around the area?
Okay.
On the,
yeah,
I think Internet of things or the future
and artificial intelligence is,
is,
is such a hot topic.
Um,
this is something different from the
American way of artificial.
I don't think artificial intelligence is
a great,
is a good word.
Proper would.
I believe it's called a machine
intelligence.
I don't,
I think human being have wisdoms.
Machine have intelligence,
an animal have instinct.
Today the artificial intelligence is
tried to make machine think like a
people.
Human Beings,
human beings only know 80% of their
brains.
And how can you make machine to learn
from the 80%
and folk sample when we've judged people
using human eyes would take a pictures
when we analyze why machine should he
take the picture and the legs that human
being machine should have as a machine
ways.
So I think today,
artificial intelligence in the western
is it?
Yes,
it's good to record but the wrong way.
And Ali Baba focus on machine
intelligence.
Machine should have do things that human
being cannot.
Well machine should learn like a human
beings are machine will never be able to
think like human beings.
Human beings have the belief had the
religion had the valley,
but she may not have.
So what I want to say is that all the
university,
especially primary school king,
the schools,
we have to be very careful the way we
teach to our kids today,
we'll meet,
make our kids so to use later,
cannot find the jobs
because machine are much smarter than
human beings.
They can calculate a faster renetta
faster.
So if we teach our kids the way we
taught in the past 100 years,
our kids were not find the jobs the next
30 years because machine would take a
lot of jobs up us.
What other things the machine can never
do.
This is something that education system,
every country should pay attention to
that though.
This is what am I view about artificial
intelligence.
And because of the date of the college,
everything,
most of the Internet of the things is
going to be meeting Internet.
Everything will be connected.
Internet.
And could you hear,
I'm sorry,
we only have one.
one question,
one final question from the students
then.
Okay.
And this will be the last question.
I'm sorry we don't have much time so
thank you.
So,
hi doctor Ma.
I'm Jonathan Iran,
third year industrial engineering from
the Gokongwei College of Engineering.
So my question is,
what is the one global issue that you
are personally passionate in solving?
Hmm,
yeah,
the global is sued that the Carson the
made a lot.
But I think,
um,
as I say,
sustainable growth that every young
people should have opportunities.
And how can we have the young people opt
to have opportunities?
We should enable them
by technology and we should change the
education system,
improve the education system.
This is something worry to me if we chit
do anything to control or improve the
environment.
But the way we teach kids,
young people are the same way we taught
in industrial time.
You'll go nowhere.
So the thing I can send the most is
about education.
We are okay now if we do not know enough
knowledge about what costs the
environment problem,
what caused the ink.
Now inclusive problems.
So these are the things that we teach
our kids,
the education systems.
That is z pie articles.
I was trained to be a high school
teacher.
I think a good education system.
Final level.
I'm the thank you.
I'm very honored to be given the
doctorate degree
that
I was considered to be a bad student.
Primary School.
I never passed examination for key
primary school.
Never God,
good middle school.
Never got ice spetters.
I try to three years for entitling our
university handjob and never be the top
10 students of my class.
Okay.
Traditional way of education.
I was considered to be a failure,
a loser,
but the way we do so what other things?
Something that we can do
for the future.
This is something that I'm thinking a
lot about,
that this is something consider me when
we have a good education system.
When we change our kids better,
our kids would not make the mistakes
that our ancestors and our generation
has made.
This is something that I can serve.
I want to really want to put efforts on
that.
Thank you very much,
Mr John.
Yeah.